hope you had a pleasant weekend i know i
did and even better there were no
witnesses so what happens when someone
admits to wrongdoing years after the
wrongdoing has been committed
for me it was getting the menudo tattoo
removed but i wonder does a confession
happen because the guilt became too much
or did they realize their confession no
longer carries any real consequence
they get to have their cake and eat it
too or in brian stelter's case
two cakes and a bucket of corn dogs
so easy so cheap but so true i speak of
this tsunami of people now admitting the
media covered up hunter biden's laptop
nearly two years later with joe as
president people are starting to admit
what we knew all along
and he said there dwell i'm sorry hunter
biden but you are and you know you made
a living being a
nerd well who was taking money just
because you were the vice president's
son and you had influence he got i think
four point yes eight million dollars
from chinese energy companies it looks
like
the left-wing media just buried the
story because it wasn't part of their
narrative and that's why people don't
trust the media it looks like it
[Laughter]
it's also like dare i say woke but in a
good way credit to mar when he's right
he's right anyway it's not just bill
even the washington post is owning up
they claim the hunter story is an
opportunity for reckoning while finally
reporting on the multi-million dollar
deals the president's son was making
with the chinese and that doesn't even
include the millions that he spent on
hookers or kung pao chicken
if hunter worked any harder for the
chinese he'd spend his weekends sowing
nikes but while the posts
admits the biden family profited from
trading overseas on his name they say it
doesn't mean joe acted corruptly you
know it's like corrupt people can't see
corruption in other people even when
it's their job to do so and tell us
about it and if his near-to-well son
suddenly earning millions is something
he wouldn't notice
like the growing stain on the front of
his trousers
but then the post asks the dumbest
question of the year
why is confirmation of a story that
surfaced in the fall of 2020 emerging
only now
gee whiz post why don't you ask your own
news bureau the press asking why the
story is only emerging now that's like
o.j simpson asking what happened to his
ex-wife nicole
or scott peterson putting up missing
posters of his wife
all around the neighborhood
your hands were all over this the
washington post then noted that after
the new york post published the
blockbuster piece quote twitter blocked
a story altogether suspended the new
york post account for sharing facebook
downrank the story and the algorithms
that govern users news feeds well thanks
guys we already knew this
there was a disinformation campaign all
right but the culprits weren't chugging
vodka in moscow they were sipping lattes
in silicon valley
but now the washington post and the new
york times have vouched for many of the
emails and cite the prompted allegations
of a cover-up or at best a double
standard in the treatment of
conservative and liberal politicians by
mainstream media and social media sites
well hello there sleepyheads did you
have a nice nap of course wapo then
offers a lame defense saying we'd all
been unwitting tools of russian
influence so it was only prudent to
suspect of a similar plot here
but these editors weren't unwitting they
were just a bunch of tools because i
don't remember them being prudent about
those other phony plots they were only
prudent about one real one
and they conclude with this solemn
idiocy the lesson learned from 2016 was
to err on the side of setting aside
questionable material in the heat of a
political campaign the lesson learned
from 2020 may well be that there's also
a danger of suppressing accurate and
relevant stories
so you see what they did there it was
important to bury it then but it's not
to bury it now which means it's time for
greg's super deluxe double whammy
conspiracy theory with 90 percent more
conspiracy and also 40 percent more
tinfoil with a drop of retson ah the
retson gets you
so the media admits to the laptop now
and not then why well the dems already
got in they won it's like paying a small
fine for behavior that earned you
millions sure paying it sucks but it
still means you got the millions in the
first place although with bite inflation
that's not worth only thousands but
could it be that the media knows
indictments are coming down so why not
speed it up get it over with away from
2024 while joe is still in power so it's
easy for him to pardon his son and maybe
his brother before joe is wheeled off on
a two-wheel hand truck like hannibal
lecter
then the dems can replace him with a
candidate who doesn't need a cheat sheet
to tell you his name and address
so they suppress to win an election that
confess to win another i wonder what joe
has to say
no no no come on man look there's no
lying anymore it's just we updated you
that's all we said the story wasn't true
now we say it's true we updated it
that's all it's like an old phone or a
computer you got to give it an update or
an at your house you do a makeover you
got to update it
this works great man like when i uh said
that putin needed to be removed from
power no no someone else came out and
they said no they gave an update that's
not true and then you asked me about i
said no
you got to go by the update
this update thing i love it it works
great you know what else i love
ice cream
who doesn't so go ahead and laugh but
the joke's on us we knew the laptop was
real but we're punished for saying it
and not the good kind of punishment that
involves a safe word so don't buy this
act of contrition the media never admits
to anything unless they're planning to
do something worse
let's welcome tonight's guest his tv
shows have inspired americans to do more
reading founder of theloftusparty.com
michael loftus
she's more conservative than a
turtleneck wearing another turtleneck
fox news contributor tammy bruce
and he's more ripped than a grocery bag
in the rain retired u.s marine corps
bomb technician and fox news contributor
johnny joey joe
[Music]
and she's like barbed wire skinny sharp
and a lot of felons can't seem to get
over her fox news contributor cantu
yeah
loftus how you doing there okay i'm
hanging in feeling good barely strong
you have no excuse to feel good but okay
i don't see why it seems like it would
go against the
evidence those are allegations
allegations i just go by how you look
and you look terrible no i'm kidding so
jesse waters of all people made a good
point on the five wow he said that the
washington post authenticated every
single email except the stuff that
mentioned joe it's like what are the
odds of that
like they walked they completely walked
around that what do you make of it that
the timing
well the timing is so they can look back
two years from now and go look we're
honest right we admit mistakes yeah but
like i'm tired of these mistakes how
many like it's like the russia collusion
mistake all the covid mistakes oh
everything about trump mistake mistake
mistake now the laptop is so these are
on purposes
these are 100 on purposes and i want
somebody to get fired okay it's like
after a while you have to send the
bouncers in all right like america is a
strip club and the media keeps
accidentally touching after a while you
got to bring in the bouncers they got to
go that's an interesting now yes america
is a stripper
yes get out your dollar bills america
yeah this is c
you look like a dollar bill tipper
i don't know why i said that because i
actually don't go to strip clubs tammy
what do you think of my theory what do
you think of my theory that this is uh
they're they're speeding this up so they
can pardon i don't even think it's my
theory but i'm gonna take credit for it
anyway uh to speed it up is so that
because they know joe's gonna be gone so
he could pardon his family that's
possible they're always thinking about
that but you know it doesn't have to be
him to pardon it can be anyone to pardon
die
sorry i'm sorry but you know what what
is nobody really discusses either is
that we always knew about the laptop we
knew what was going on and then suddenly
they're you know saying oh they're
realizing it because the newspapers are
saying it might be true they've known it
all along yeah they've they've known
from the start
said nothing as everything was being
blocked away said nothing as it was
being described as russian uh you know
disinformation
and they knew it was different
disinformation and they said nothing in
the process right that alone
really indicts them when it comes to
their intention
and why else would they do that they
wouldn't do it if it was just hunter
it's never been about hunter it's always
been about the big guy the big guy it's
always been about him that you know you
can throw hunter under the bus it's it's
not going to save joe biden but all of
this is about joe biden that's the
difference and i think you know look
hillary just got fined for the dossier
because they lied to the fbi lord knows
we would love to just be fined for
committing you know what the fbi might
consider a crime
the this is the crowd that thinks this
is what will happen to them they'll like
you said they'll have to pay a little
bit of money and then they'll go merrily
along their way that has to change you
can't throw a hunter under the bus
because then the bus will get hepatitis
oh yeah
joey uh
tammy makes a really good point that
that it's it there's something about
telling the truth and people know you're
telling the truth and say you're a liar
and then later say oh yeah it was true
it's like it's like it's like if you
were a kid and you went to a teacher and
said that you were being bullied or
something like that and they just blow
it off and then it happens you know i
don't know
i mean i use the stripper analogy
instead well imagine you're a stripper
oddly enough in the marine corps we
called a stripper an update because like
we're on a date but she just happens to
be up there
very good best i got very good but on
this on this particular story with 105
minutes like that was terrible i liked
it
clever this is the most obvious don't
spit in my face and tell me it's raining
i mean yeah no revelations here
whatsoever other than major media
outlets we're willing to say oh my god
that they were telling the truth the
whole time what what and now what i love
about this is the self-righteous spin
we must
take account for ourselves you know like
in the washington post article no you
don't need to take account for yourself
you've got caught with your proverbial
pants down you have no choice and
they're trying to buy back a little bit
of credibility because i think i think
they're circling the wagons what better
opportunity to get rid of joe biden as
democrats than when he's at the bottom
of the you you you let truth come out
and what you do is you hang all this
baggage on his arms on his way out the
door yeah exactly you know then you let
kamala ruin it for a couple of years
the next republican comes in gives you
four years worth of stuff to attack him
or her on right and hopefully you find
someone with a heartbeat you know that
can that can be your next savior i think
they're gonna unload both of them up at
the same time i don't know if that's
possible but i you know i've been
talking to some insiders you can't
[ __ ]
well she may be appointed kamala may be
appointed to some cabinet position
because she knows that there's no
support you can't fire a disabled
veteran in a patriotic uh position right
like when i went to work for my old boss
look make sure you want me because you
can't fire me people right
yeah you can't fire kamala yeah
i've been trying to fire cat but she's
half a veteran there you go yeah
[Laughter]
that is why i got married we have that
in common yeah what's worse the contents
on hunter's laptop or yours
um
probably his
there's nothing bad on mine don't we
deserve some kind of
like uh i would with some kind of pe uh
the press should pay a penalty to the
people who were right there should be a
fine paid to me personally like a large
sum of money from the washington post
should go into my pocket just make it a
compliment yes
yeah a nice compliment what do you think
yeah i would love that a compliment
i i love compliments um but yeah or at
least to like admit it and rather than
act like it's some kind of mystery yeah
which they i guess they sort of admitted
it like hey we have to do a reckoning
here but they all said like why
why did they take this take so long
thing is absurd when you're talking
about yourself like how about you ask
yourself and then write about that but i
think a lot of these people would still
say that trust in the media is low
because of you know donald trump said
don't trust the media even though it's
really low among americans overall and
independence yeah because they still
don't get it i don't think they want to
get it because sometimes
understanding things can be painful and
think about how many hunter laptops
metaphorically are are representative of
stories we never heard that are out
there that have cost lives yes that have
been covered up because you know it
would have it would have hurt you know a
clinton you know or or anybody for that
matter you know i want public firings